The Huns played an instrumental part in destroying
the Western Roman Empire, the Avars brought
the Eastern Roman Empire to almost the same
fate, the Khazars stopped Arab expansion across
the Caucasus while in the process drastically
weakening the Umayyad Caliphate, and the Nomads
of the Mongol Steppe were such a threat to
China that numerous Chinese dynasties all
across the ages spent enormous amounts of
resources on large wall building projects
just to keep the Nomads out.
It is undeniable that the early medieval nomads
of the Eurasian Steppe had a tremendous impact
on Euroasian history and, therefore, it would
be nice to know how these nomads lived in
the steppe, especially since a lot of what
we know about them isn’t very accurate.
Before we delve into the complicated life
of the early medieval Euroasian steppe quote
unquote “nomads”, we have to talk about
the polities that existed in the steppe during
this time just to give some background.
We will start off in the 6th century with
the First Turkic Khaganate.
There were many nomadic polities before then
but we have to start off somewhere and the
First Turkic Khaganate is a perfect starting
point as it gave rise to many nomadic groups
that influenced Eurasian politics for the
rest of the medieval period.
The First Turkic Khaganate emerged after the
Gokturks, an early Turkic tribe, successfully
rebelled against their Rouran overlords and
took control of their state in 552.
Subsequently Gokturks went on to conquer much
of the Euroasian steppe.
The Gokturks came as far as the Byzantine
controlled Crimea in 576 and even laid siege
to the city of Chersonesus, today’s Sewastopol.
The Avars that came to Pannonia during the
6th century and established the Avar Khaganate
were fleeing from the Gokturk conquest.
There is a theory that the Avars were the
Rouran that were defeated by the Gokturks
and fled west, however, this is hard to prove.
The Avars could have easily been one of the
many nomadic tribes in the steppe that just
didn’t want to get conquered by the First
Turkic Khaganate.
Nonetheless, wherever they came from, the
Avars, along the way to Pannonia, subdued
the Bulgar tribes living around the Don river.
In c. 584 a succession crisis in the First
Turkic Khaganate led to a civil war which
lasted until 603 when the civil war got resolved
by splitting the Khaganate into two.
The Western Turkic Khaganate and the Eastern
Turkic Khaganate.
The Eastern Turkic Khaganate was then subdued
by the Tang Dynasty in 630 becoming their
vassals.
In the west the Bulgars rebelled against the
Avars in 632 establishing the Old Great Bulgaria.
During that time with the fall of the Eastern
Turkic Khaganate, the Western Turkic Khaganate
wasn’t fairing any better and in around
the 630s it started to lose control over the
various nomadic tribes living within its borders,
the most notable of these tribes were the
Khazars.
The Khazars broke off from the control of
the Western Turkic Khaganate at some point
between 630 and 650 consolidating power south
of the Volga river.
Once they emerged as a consolidated polity
they started to look outwards trying to conquer
the Bulgars to the West, the Kangar Union
to the East and also fighting the Arabs to
the south.
The Kangar Union was a collection of various
nomadic tribes that, under the leadership
of the Kangars, rebelled against the Western
Turkic Khaganate when it was invaded and subdued
by the Tang dynasty in 657.
In 668 after the death of their Khagan the
Old Great Bulgaria finally succumbed to the
Khazars with some of the Bulgars migrating
North and Establishing Volga Bulgaria and
some migrating west and establishing the First
Bulgarian Kingdom.
In 682 the Gokturks of the Eastern Turkic
Khaganate, who were the vassals of the Tang,
successfully rebelled against the Chinese
and started to consolidate power in the steppe
once again.
In 712 they conquered what remained of the
Western Turkic Khaganate, which was now called
the Turgesh Khaganate as the Turgesh took
control of the Khaganate away from the Gokturks.
With this conquest of the Turgesh Khaganate
the Gokturks of the Eastern Turkic Khaganate
formed what we call today the Second Turkic
Khaganate.
During the formation of the Second Turkic
Khaganate the Gokturks violently subdued a
nomadic tribe called the Uyghurs who subsequently
started to plot against them.
Also around the late 7th century the Umayyad
forces took control of the Amu and Syr darya
rivers away from the Kangar Union and in the
early 8th century the Arabs came into conflict
with the Tang Empire over the valuable trading
area of Sogdia.
This fighting was marked with frequent involvement
of the various local nomadic tribes from the
Second Turkic Khaganate, most notably the
Turgesh and the Oghuz.
In 744 the Uyghurs, now with new allies, led
a rebellion against the Gokturks and overthrew
them ending the Second Turkic Khaganate.
Subsequently the Uyghurs established a new
nomadic polity known as the Uyghur Khaganate.
As part of consolidating power within this
new Khaganate the Uyghurs attacked one of
their allies that helped them overthrow the
Gokturks, the Karluks.
After this attack the Karluks migrated west
to the land of the Oghuz and the Turgesh who
they defeated and took control of their land.
The Turgesh assimilated into the Karluks while
the defeated Oghuz had no choice but to migrate
west into the Kangar Union.
There the Oghuz allied with the Kimaks, who
were under Kangar control, and overthrew the
Kangars.
The defeated Kangars united with the remaining
tribes still loyal to them and formed a new
tribe called the Pechenegs.
The Pechenegs subsequently migrated westwards
fighting off the Khazars and settling around
the Ural river.
The victorious Oghuz and Kimaks then divided
the Kangar lands and formed their own polities
in the area in c. 750.
These polities were called the Kimak Khaganate
and the Oghuz Yabgu State.
Oghuz also managed to reconquer some parts
of the Syr Darya river from the Arabs and
the Uyghurs managed to get hold of some Sogdian
trading cities.
This is where I will end the VERY oversimplified
summary of the early medieval Euroasian Steppe.
Keep in mind that the sources about this area
and this period are very sparse and, therefore,
the details of these events are very much
still debated today by historians.
Due to that some historians may present slightly
different versions of events that occurred
in this area during this time, specially when
it comes to territorial control of the various
polities mentioned as that is probably one
of the hardest things to pinpoint.
With that said, now that you’re more confused
than ever about the history of the Euroasian
steppe, we can delve into the lifestyles of
the people that lived in this land of constant
flux.
But not before I tell you about this video's
sponsor.
This video is sponsored by Private Internet
Access, the most transparent VPN provider
with over 30 million downloads.
I have actually been using Private Internet
Access personally for over 2 years now, and
I like how it helps me protect my data from
my ISP and access geo-restricted content.
What drew me into using Private Internet Access
as a personal VPN was the fact that they're
very unique.
Even though they protect your private data
through the fact that they're a VPN, many
VPN companies still log your activity, and
I've always found that very counterintuitive.
However, Private Internet Access doesn't do
this.
They have a strict policy about not storing
any of your data which has even been tested
in court.
What's more, the app is 100% open source,
so you can see for yourself that Private internet
access doesn't keep any tabs on you.
Add to that the fact that Private Internet
Access is available on all platforms, Windows,
Android, iOS, and Linux or that you can use
one subscription to protect 10 different devices,
and you have a great product.
Not to mention that its UI is really easy
to use.
I mean, I can use it, and I am a historian.
So, if you want to join me and start using
Private Internet, now's the perfect time because
there's a massive discount available for you.
Click the link in the description and get
Private Internet Access for 83% off!
That's just $2.08 a month, and you also get
2 extra months for free!
Plus, you're protected by a 30-day money-back
guarantee, and Customer Support is available
24/7, so signing up is risk-free, and I definitely
recommend it.
Thank you to Private Internet Access, for
sponsoring this video!
- 6:44 : 6:57 - The animation used here stays
on for a long time, but it has no connection
to the voice-over.
Instead, you can be shown the animation from
this page when you click with VPN - without
VPN (the Benefits Of Hiding Your IP Address
section)
- 7:46 - you say 3 dollars and 3 cents a month.
That should be to 2 dollars and 8 cents.
Now that we have discussed the various steppe
polities of the early medieval Period and
the way they were established and destroyed
we can discuss more closely the life of the
steppe “nomads” that lived in these polities.
When people picture the history of the Eurasian
steppe they often picture an endless sea of
grasslands filled with nomads living in yurts
that sporadically follow their animal herds
wherever they happen to migrate.
These nomads then intermittently formed into
bigger political groups and marched into the
civilized world where they caused chaos and
destruction.
This picture, however, is filled with stereotypes
and isn’t very accurate.
The nomads of the Eurasian steppe could build
up or destroy powerful empires, they could
form complex social hierarchies and even build
cities the splendour of which impressed their
local “sedentary” counterparts.
None of this could be done by a society which
solely centred around herding and migrating.
The early medieval nomadic societies of the
Euroasian steppe were far more complex than
is often talked about.
Probably the most important thing to mention
here, is that the Eurasian Steppe in the early
medieval period did have urban centres or
at least settlements.
Of course, these were on average smaller than
the urban centres of China or Persia and there
were less of them, but they did exist.
The Euroasian steppe was not some kind of
a sea of neverending grasslands with no farming
or settlements or urban centres.
The trading cities on the Syr Darya river
are well documented, as are the Khazar trading
cities on the Volga and Don, and the Uyghur
capital was said to have been so magnificent
it could rival any city in the “urbanized”
world.
Even in today’s northern Kazakhstan, an
area believed to have been devoid of any urbanization,
a 9th century Arab explorer Tamim ibn Bahr
wrote of Kimak “villages and cultivated
tracts of land” around the Irtysh river.
As you can see the early medieval Euroasian
steppe contained settled people who farmed
and also urban centres that produced goods,
materials and traded with the rest of the
world.
Yes, there most certainly were a majority
of nomads in the steppe that did live a life
dictated by sporadic seasonal migrations of
their herds, but this was by far not the only
lifestyle present in the steppe nor was this
lifestyle static for the people that lived
it.
By that I mean the nomads weren’t always
nomadic.
People who lived a nomadic life in the steppe
could and did embrace a sedentary lifestyle
either by choice or when social, economic,
and political pressures forced them into it.
For example, the Khazars found themselves
in control of the extremely valuable Volga
and Don river trade routes and to consolidate
control over this trade they constructed and
settled in cities along the rivers.
The Khazars were nomads who, forced by political
and economic pressures, had to consolidate
power by becoming, at least in part, sedentary.
This is not to say that all Khazars became
sedentary, for example the Khazar ruling class
was said to have only wintered in their capital
of Atil, and there were Khazar people that
did continue on herding in the Southern Russia
Steppe, but it does go to show that nomads
could and did sometimes embrace sedentary
lifestyles.
In contrast to that, settled people in the
steppe, who might have been former nomads
themselves, could also abandon a settled or
an urban life and become nomads again.
This happened when a Gokturk Khagan of the
Second Turkic Khaganate attacked the Uyghurs.
He stated that “I marched down along the
Selenga river and there laid waste to their
[Uyghur] settlements.”
further stating that Uyghurs dispersed mostly
east but also west.
The Uyghur settlements were destroyed and
so the Uyghurs had to go back to a nomadic
life in the steppe, biding their time and
finding new allies before attacking the Gokturks
and destroying their Khaganate as we already
talked about.
Hopefully with these examples it has become
clear that a nomadic steppe life wasn’t
stagnant, it could involve months, years or
even generations of sedentary existence before
reverting back to nomadic herding, or vice
versa.
The nomads of the Euroasian steppe were not
foreign to the idea of farming or settling
in an urban centre.
They were also aware that successfully running
a polity required some sort of centralized
leadership, administration, and management.
This is why when new nomadic polities came
to be, like that of the Khazar or Uyghur Khaganate,
the nomads knew they had to construct cities
and so they did.
However, this centralization, urbanization,
and settlement was not always successful or
welcomed by some members of the nomadic communities
within newly formed polities.
For example there was a very prominent Gokturk
general in the Second Turkic Khaganate, called
Tonyukuk, who vehemently believed that “the
only way for them (the nomadic Turks) to maintain
their national identity was ‘to follow the
water and the grass’ (meaning a nomadic
lifestyle) and have no permanent dwellings.
If the Turks were to change their old customs,
he argued, one day they would be defeated
and annexed by the Chinese.”
Thanks to people like Tonyukuk we know that
the idea of a nomadic life vs a settled life
was a subject of debate in nomadic communities.
Therefore, as with almost everything, the
nomadic life of the Eurasian steppe was a
spectrum with people on one side arguing for
a settled life and urban centres and people
on the other for a nomadic life.
Most nomads most likely fell somewhere in
between these two extremes.
Which is why we see a variety of lifestyles
in the Eurasian steppe, and why a nomadic
life was fluid and could contain nomads settling
in cities and then also due to a variety of
reasons abandoning these cities and becoming
nomads again.
Another aspect of the Euroasian steppe nomads
that is often misrepresented is their autarky,
in other words their self-sufficiency.
The nomads of the Eurasian steppe were not
at all autarkic.
On the contrary, they needed a steady stream
of goods like pottery or silk and raw materials
like iron or wood from sedentary societies.
The nomads simply just couldn’t get hold
of, or produce, all these goods in big enough
quantities and therefore relied on sedentary
societies.
There were several ways the nomads acquired
these goods and materials from these sedentary
societies.
First was from the urban centres that already
existed in the Eurasian steppe, in fact one
of the theories for why there were settlements
in the Eurasian steppe is that they were created
to fulfill an economic need.
This is, however, still debated.
Second way of getting these goods and materials
was through just trading, this is partly why
nomads were often so keen on exploiting trade
routes like the Khazars did and why they often
tried to conquer areas significant for trading,
like the Silk Road.
Third was raiding urban centres, or through
coercion of tribute payments of goods and
materials to not raid these urban centres,
pretty self explanatory.
Fourth was conquering sedentary societies
and then exploiting them, kind of like the
Avars did with the Slavs, or the Uyghurs with
the Sogdians.
Lastly, fifth, was nomads building their own
urban centres and producing their own goods
and materials.
Most notable example of this was the Uyghur
capital of Ordu-Baliq which was reported by
arab explorers in the 9th century as being
“a great city, rich in agriculture and surrounded
by districts full of cultivation and villages
lying close together.
The city has twelve iron gates of huge size.
The city is also populous and thickly crowded
and has markets and various traders.”
Through archaeology we can also gleam that
the city had sizable hinterlands which focused
on production of goods most certainly to fulfil
the needs of the nomadic polity.
Of course, none of these five ways of acquiring
goods and materials were mutually exclusive
and all these solutions were used interchangeably
by various nomadic groups.
With all that said, there’s a very good
reason why when it comes to the Euroasian
steppe nomads the “nomadic” aspect of
their life is often overemphasized by people
talking about their history.
This mostly happens because the nomadic life
is what made the nomads so unique and it is
the thing that gave them the edge over their
sedentary counterparts.
Their lifestyle was the reason why the Euroasian
nomads were time and time again so influential
in Euroasian history.
The nomadic lifestyle forced the people of
the steppe to become very good at horse riding,
archery, and be self-sufficient for long periods
of time.
As discussed they still needed goods and materials
from sedentary people but they could live
without these things for far longer than any
other sedentary people could.
All these skills which the nomads learned
in the steppe coincidentally also made them
skilled and efficient warriors.
They were perfect soldiers for military campaigns
as they could mobilize and travers great distances
in a short amount of time.
On top of that, the fact that a nomadic lifestyle
required the involvement of everyone in the
nomadic society meant that despite smaller
population numbers the nomads of the Euroasian
steppe could field just as large armies as
their much more populous sedentary neighbors.
Almost everyone in the nomadic society could
be a skilled warrior if needed.
Therefore, it was the nomadic lifestyle that
empowered the Euroasian nomads to be so influential
in Euroasian history and that is why their
“nomadic” life is often emphasized in
most literature about them which, however,
overshadows the more nuanced reality.
The reality being that most early medieval
Euroasian nomads did live a nomadic life which
however, was not self-sufficient, not stagnant,
and not devoid of farming or urban centres
as is often thought.
Just as any people the nomads were pragmatic
and when needed they could settle and farm
or build cities to centralize power or abandon
all this and start herding again.